So good morning.
Everyone 9 AM on the West Coast.
I'm Alex Bui, Co-director of the BD2K Centers
Coordination Center.
So today, we continue our computing overview
with what I believe is our fifth talk in this
section.
I have the distinct pleasure of introducing
Dr. Vivien Bonazzi of NIH.
Dr. Bonazzi is the Senior Adviser for Data
Science Technologies and the Commons, which
is what she'll be talking about shortly.
She serves on the BD2K executive committee
and leads a variety of data science and sustainability
efforts through the National Institutes of
Health.
She holds a PhD in molecular pharmacology
and computational biology from the University
of Melbourne and was a senior associate at
Booz Allen Hamilton, managing several genome
and protein bioinformatics projects there.
As part of NIH, she has served as the program
director for the National Human Genome Research
Institute and was part of the Human Microbiome
Project, where she was responsible for the
bioinformatic and computational elements of
that effort.
So please join me in welcoming Dr. Bonazzi
this morning.
She'll be giving us some insights about the
relatively new and exciting NIH Commons.
So Dr. Bonazzi, thank you for joining us today.
The floor is yours.
Right.
Good morning, everyone.
Thank you, Alex.
Thank you for the opportunity to speak to
you today.
So today, I'm going to talk to you a little
bit about the Commons, but also just give
you a few updates on where we are with that,
which is the context of this talk today.
So I'm just going to-- can everyone see my
screen?
Is the answer to that yes, Alex, to you, at
least?
Hello?
Can you hear me?
Alex, can you hear me?
Hello?
We can hear you.
OK, great.
I'm just trying to get my slides to advance.
All right, so the previous slide was just
a little bit about myself.
Let's keep moving.
So I'm going to talk to you a little bit about
biomedical big data.
I don't know what all of the audience's background
is, so I'm going to assume something in biomedical
areas and some different degrees in terms
of data science.
And I'm going to try and build up a picture
of, essentially, why we would need something
like the Commons, and how we're going to approach
it in NIH.
So starting, really, at its basic level, this
is the kind of data that NIH is well known
for.
A lot of it is-
So starting, really, at its basic level, this
is the kind of data that NIH is well known
for.
A lot of it is-a lot of it was analog, but
it's moving more and more to digital sciences.
And I think we see that from some of the examples
I'm just showing here.
And as we get more towards wearables and collecting
that kind of information, we're obviously
going towards more and more data collection
as well.
So I think this slide is something that, maybe,
people have seen before, which is, we hear
about the four Vs related to big data.
I've heard of several different other ones.
And that is the Volume, as in the amount;
the Velocity, which is the speed at which
you need to process this information, and
it's coming up very quickly; the Variety,
in terms of the different data types that
we have; and then the Veracity, which is really
the trustworthiness of the data and its cleanliness.
Can you really trust it, and can you use it?
These are the ones that I've seen a lot of,
and I've seen a few others.
But one of the ones that I want to focus on
today is also this, which is that I think
that data has value.
And it's, I think, a signal of the coming
digital economy that I think we're all realizing
we're in, and that data is really central
to that particular digital economy.
I think that economy is characterized by using
data to gain a business advantage.
And I think, yes, institutions, not just commercial
entities, are businesses when we come to data,
and I think that organizations that aren't
born digital will be at a disadvantage in
that new economy.
So I think organizations will be defined by
their digital assets in the future.
And by digital assets, I mean these, in terms
of the sciences-- that is, data, software,
workflows, documentations, journal articles,
and there's probably others here, as well,
that I could include.
But I think these are the ones that most people
would know about.
And I think what's really important here is
that a lot of the most successful organizations
of the future will be those that can leverage
those digital assets and, importantly, transform
them into a digital enterprise.
How do we pull all these pieces together,
is the question we have to ask.
We know we have the pieces, but what do we
need to do?
I think one of the key ones is to make data
the central currency of an organization.
And it's really usable in a digital ecosystem,
in the context of where we're talking about
the Commons.
So really, the transactions of using data
is really what the Commons facilitates.
And I'm going to go through that in a little
more detail now.
So let's have a look a little bit about the
problem with biomedical data.
And when I talked about digital assets before,
I want to say that includes data.
It isn't just data.
And I think there are lots of
challenges in biomedical data, and that is--
and they fall in a couple of different categories.
There is the journal article, which is still,
I think, the end goal of many scientists.
And that's fine, but the data, which is seen
as a means to an end, is really low value.
And I think the argument I was just making
before is that data actually has value, and
it's higher than what we're giving it at the
moment.
The data is not FAIR, and that is the term
that is being used fairly recently.
I'm assuming that listeners have heard of
this term, but those that don't, I'm implying
that it's Findable, Accessible, Interoperable,
and Reproducible.
And there have been a number of papers over
the last few years which talk about this--
that in fact, if we're going to give data
value, it has to have these properties here
in order to be able to do something with it.
I think there are also limited infrastructures
to support FAIR data.
And I think what the Commons is trying to
do is going some way towards doing that.
So here is just a short presentation, which
is from the New York Health Sciences Library.
Some of you may have seen this-- it's quite
long.
The original is actually quite long.
I've just taken a short abstract from it to
sort of identify the problems with data.
And this little YouTube video really encapsulates
the issues with data.
I think it's only about a minute and a bit
long, so I'm going to play that now.
The link to the full video shown here at the
bottom of the screen, so you can go to YouTube
and actually have a look at that.
So here it is.
Enjoy.
Hopefully the audio will play for you.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Hi.
- Hello.
- My name is Dr. Judy Benign.
I'm an oncologist at NYU School of Medicine.
- Hello, Dr.
Judy Benign.
- I read your article about B cell functions.
It was very interesting.
I think that I could use the data for my work
on pancreatic cancer.
- I am not an oncologist.
- I know, but I think I could use the data
for my work on pancreatic cancer.
- Oh.
- So do you have the data?
- Everything you need to know is in the article.
- No, what I need is the data.
Will you
share your data?
- I am not sure that will be possible.
- But your work is in PubMed Central and was
funded by NIH.
- That is true.
- And it was published in Science, which requires
that you share your data.
- I did publish in Science.
- Then I am requesting your data.
Can I have a copy of your data?
- Everything you need to know is in the article.
- No.
- I am not sure where my data is.
- But surely you saved your data.
- I did.
I saved it on a USB drive.
- Where is the USB drive?
- It is in a box.
It is in a box at home.
I just moved.
- But can I use your data?
- There are many boxes.
Well, I forgot to label the boxes.
[END PLAYBACK]
And as you can see, I think this encapsulates
a lot of the problems that we're seeing with
data.
It's a small vignette.
I highly recommend watching the entire video.
It's in three parts.
So what's changing?
We know what the problems are, but let's have
a look at what's actually changing.
I think one of the things I just mentioned
before, which is the issue about making data
FAIR, which is Findable, Accessible, Interoperable,
and Reproducible, and I've just shown a clipping
here from the [? Walkerson ?] paper that came
out about a year and a half-- year ago that
actually starts addressing this.
There have been a couple of additional papers
around this area.
And I think what it's doing is really explaining
what you need to think about when you're dealing
with data and the kinds of issues that you
need to be considering when you're dealing
with data overall.
And I think this is having an impact at all
sorts of different levels, from institutions
like NIH, but I know it's also having an impact
across different government institutions,
both in the United States, certainly in Europe,
also Australia, and in Asia.
And I think what you're going to see is the
applications of these two data sets as we
move forward.
Another key issue that's, I think, changing,
that's hopefully avoiding what we just saw
in that short video, is the data sharing policies
from funding agencies like NIH, but I think
other agencies that also deal with data, which
is making the data shareable-- not just in
a form, as in making data FAIR, but also having
policies saying we want things to be shared,
looking at open data and the standards associated
with that, and the things that go along with
grants that are actually paid by NIH, and
ensuring that that data is made available.
But I think we're also seeing a couple other
things, and that is that when you store your
data, that you're moving towards-- instead
of just having it on local repositories or
in general archive repositories-- we're actually
looking at, now, research data repositories,
which store data per se.
And there are a number of these that have
been coming about, and I think that's also
a change in the way that we're looking at
data, making these available in a fair format,
but also having them available to the broader
community, rather than just a USB drive, which
is what the previous YouTube video showed.
I think the other thing is metadata.
Metadata is really important in describing
the data that you have.
And ensuring that it has quality standards
around it is really important.
There have been many projects at NIH which
have used metadata, but not particularly well,
or used community standards.
And this is critical for the way that you
actually want to index this information, and
search it, and make it findable by others
and usable by others.
Another one which is-- another change that
I'm seeing is the use of the unique identifiers-ensuring
that we have identifiers for the data per
se that are consistent and also to formulated
standards.
And standards are starting to come across
this area.
So I think where the YouTube video showed
a lot of problems, I think here are some of
the areas that I think we're starting to see
some change, which is starting to enable the
better use of data and to see value in the
system.
But I think we're still in the early days
of this, and I think it's important that it
happens from the ground up, from the PhD students
all the way up to the leaders of the institutions,
to embrace these kinds of changes and to enable
them within their organizations, or even at
a small level, as graduate
students actually do this within their own
work.
So I think what we're also trying to get at
here is that the FAIR principles drive data
to become the currency.
If you actually can describe it, you know
what it is, it's interoperable, it's reproducible,
it's basically an apples-to-apples comparison,
you can understand what it is that you have.
And I think what we also need to look at are
policies that promote data sharing via FAIR,
can really help change that culture, which
is why I think the leveraging of fair principles,
and turning those into guidelines that the
community can use within the context of their
own data, really will help promote this kind
of work.
So that's great.
You make data FAIR.
But then I think what we also need is ecosystems
that allow transactions to occur on that FAIR
data.
And importantly for biomedical data, you want
to do this at scale.
We all know, particularly from genome studies,
but I think also from some of the brain studies,
where you're looking at not just genomic data,
but also imaging studies from those things,
that the data is large and getting larger.
And it's quite cheap to generate the data,
but it's a lot of effort on the other end
to store it, and also to look at harmonization
and to deal with all of these FAIR concepts.
So I think what we want to do is to do all
of these things, to look at the way we handle
data in the future.
So now I want to talk a little bit about the
Data Commons.
Up until now, I've just explained the kinds
of things that we're seeing.
I think much of the community knows about
big data, but I've tried to sort of lay the
groundwork about the sort of pieces around
the data, the problems, and the things that
are changing.
As I just mentioned, what you also need to
think about is the way a platform works here
to support this whole ecosystem.
And really, the work that's going on in the
Data Commons is really that.
It's looking at a platform that fosters the
development of a digital ecosystem to support
transactions on FAIR data.
So I'm just going to talk a little bit about
some of the principles behind the Commons,
as we see it.
And that is, as I just mentioned, it's a platform
that fosters development of a digital ecosystem.
But it treats the products of research, whatever
they are, as digital assets.
And as I mentioned before, these will be the
currencies of institutions in the future.
We want all of these digital objects to conform
to FAIR principles, as I've just said before.
And we
want these digital objects to exist in some
sort of shared virtual space so that you can
find them, deposit, manage, share, reuse--
essentially do work on these objects, and
do science.
And you want to you create a platform, because
the platforms enable interactions between
producers and consumers of those digital assets.
And I think there are many biomedical scientists
who produce information that want it to be
consumed by others, and what we want is some
sort of level exchange to do that.
It also gives currencies to the digital assets,
and the people who develop and support them.
One of the big issues is that the papers that
are produced can often have PIs, and that's
important to do that, but a lot of the people
that do the data scrubbing, the informaticians,
some of the software engineers, don't get
the kind of currency that they really need
when they're actually working on these digital
assets.
And I think papers are great, but it would
also just be very helpful, and I think really
good, to give currency to the digital assets
themselves, be they-- whatever they are.
And I think the most common ones right now
that people look at are data and software.
And if somebody developed those, they get
attribution for that.
And there is a way to do that that isn't necessarily
a paper.
And I think we're starting to see elements
of that-- you see that, certainly, within
GitHub, and you see it within data repositories
that are just involved in sorting data, particularly
from papers.
So I mentioned before that the Data Commons
is a platform.
So I'd like to talk to you a little bit more
about a platform.
And it's essentially a platform that fosters
that development of the ecosystem.
So let's talk a little bit about what that
might look like.
And we're in the fairly early days of this.
So I'm going to take a quote here from a fellow
that I've been doing some work with, here,
which is Sangeet Paul Choudary, who's been
looking at-- he's written a book called Platforms
of Scale.
This slide has a link to that.
I presume these slides will be made public.
I'll certainly put them on my SlideShare afterwards,
and you'll be able to download them.
Sangeet looks at platforms in the digital
space, and I'll explain those in one minute.
But here, he's saying, "Platforms is a plug
and play model allows multiple participants,
the producers and consumers, to connect to
it, to interact with each other, and to create
value."
And what Sangeet just been looking at specifically
is all of these platforms, that if I just
showed you this icon, you'll identify pretty
much all of them.
A very classic one is AirBnB, right?
It's a platform that allows producers and
consumers to interact
with vacant apartments, houses, essentially
accommodation, with people who need that.
And he's been looking at how those platforms
are set up to connect producers and consumers,
and what really allows them to work, and what
are their business models behind that.
So as I mentioned before, but I think it's
worth stating again, that you want interactions
between producers and consumers.
So somebody who generates biomedical data
and often the tools, but not necessarily just
that, wants to be able to share that information
with others, either within a consortium or
with just others in the future who want to
consume it-- say, if they have an new grant
that they want to submit, or application they
want to submit to NIH.
So to understand the Data Commons Platform,
and really, how it might work for biomedical
sciences, I'm going to use what's called a
platform stack to help visualize this concept.
Sangeet looks at it in terms of the broader
digital community, but I think it's really
important for us to look at some of the layers
that are really consistent amongst every single
one of these platforms that he's been talking
about, and certainly consistent with the ones
I just showed before, and examples were Uber,
AirBnB, et cetera.
They're really in three layers.
There's a technology infrastructure component,
there's a data component, and there's a network
marketplace community that consumes this information.
In the context of the Data Commons for NIH,
this is something I've been working on over
the last 18 months or so, and really looking
at, OK, how do we look at this-- if this is
a platform to support data at-- for NIH data,
what's the right way to think about it?
And this is something that's just a model
of that stack, and a diagram.
I'll just walk through it just briefly, here.
So the bottom layer is the technology layer.
This is where we have a compute platform.
You want to operate on the data in some form.
We are going to leverage cloud services at
NIH, in part because we see a great deal of
researchers, particularly using large data,
moving from repositories to clouds-- commercial
clouds-- essentially doing some work on it,
some form of analysis, and once they've done
their analysis, they remove it from the cloud,
and they have their results.
But they generally don't leave their data
sets up there, because storage costs are too
high, and certainly, moving multiple petabytes
of data would incur a huge number of costs
for them.
So we're looking at, what's the right way
to use the cloud platform to facilitate the
researchers at NIH?
In saying that, we're also dealing with supercompute
facilities.
They're primarily funded through DOE, not
NIH, but we're working with them to figure
out how we can collaborate.
But essentially, bottom line is, you've got
a technology platform here, which is cloud
supercompute.
S
The next layer is data, and we have a collection
of data that-- some of those are from large
generated data sets, which are funded by NIH.
These are often-- I call them reference data
sets.
They're in the, certainly, terabyte to petabyte
range, generated by NIH, usually under consortiums,
and with the intent to share.
And just some of the examples I can think
of, there are the encode data sets, which
are used by the community, and also the GTEx
data sets, are some examples of ones that
I've been dealing with.
These are large, hundreds of terabyte, petabyte
data sets, which people want to consume, but
they can't do that either locally, in their
own systems, or at the repositories, because
they simply don't have the compute resources
to it.
But we also have user-defined data, in the
sense that people have smaller data sets that
they actually want to bring to these larger
data sets, perhaps, and actually do some sort
of analysis.
But the bottom layer is that you've got a
whole bunch of data which needs to be computed
against.
And then the top layer here is really saying
that if you have a platform with data, you
want to be able to do various things to it.
And the most common thing that people see
is, you want to do some sort of analysis on
it-- scientific analysis.
But to do that in these environments, you
also need to have a collection of services
to enable you to do that.
First of all, you need to find this information,
so you need some for of indexing.
This is where the metadata becomes really
important.
But also any APIs that can access the data,
and you also want, particularly if you're
using the cloud, containers.
A common form of that would be, say, Docker
containers.
So there are a series of services that enable
you to use this data in these particular environments,
and we need to pay attention to those, as
well as the scientific analysis tools that
you want to use to actually operate on the
data.
And on the top of all of that, I think what
you want is to have some form of interface
which allows you to access a collection of
these data sets appropriately, and some sort
of, really, marketplace to allow those interactions
to drive innovation.
The other thing you need to do is, obviously,
have digital object compliance, and this touches
on the FAIR principles.
So essentially, this stack is three parts--
some form of compute, a whole of data from
NIH in some form, or biomedical data in general,
and our collections of services and tools
that allow you to operate on that data-- on
FAIR data.
If you want more information, there's a link
at the bottom of the slide that takes you
to far more detailed information at the Commons,
if you want to read about
[? it.
?]
A couple of other things I just want to point
out, again, looking at platforms in general.
If you look at this in the context of [INAUDIBLE]
the way IT sees it, the bottom layer is really
the infrastructure as a service.
And then the layers around the data, and the
tools around those, the services and the analytics,
these are really platforms for software as
a service.
And I think this is where we're starting to
see some play, certainly, in the market.
We're seeing a lot SaaS providers out there,
certainly in biomedical sciences.
But you're certainly seeing it in other areas
as well, and I'll show a couple of examples
of those in a minute.
But I think we're also going to see a drive
to data as a service in the long term, because
I think, really, data is going to be the currency
to this.
And how that looks like, I think we're just
starting to understand those pieces.
Just a moment about digital object compliance,
this is really about making things FAIR.
I won't go through this in a lot of detail.
I'll just say that there are key aspects of
this that we need.
We need digital object identifiers that resolve
to original sources that's machine readable,
and you have a minimal set of metadata, and
you have clear access rules and entry in indices.
If you do this, I think what that does is,
it allows us to move towards FAIRness, essentially.
This slide was done a little while ago.
So our initial focus was looking at this,
and what we've actually started to do is develop
working groups within BD2K, but also reaching
out more broadly across the community to look
at developing FAIR guidelines.
What does that really mean, to be FAIR?
And that group, I think, started last year,
and it's just starting to gather steam.
And the purpose is to develop guidelines to
share those with the community.
Right, here's some examples of just platforms.
I'm not endorsing any of these.
I'm just simply saying, here are examples.
This is a SaaS application that a lot of people
who do genomics probably know, which is DNAnexus,
that allows you, essentially, to develop--
to use pipelines and various tools, essentially,
over clouds.
And they have a lot of genomic data, and the
purpose of this company, I think, is to enable
scientists to really use data at scale.
And it's very much a platform that follows
some of the principles I just showed for the
Commons.
Another one is, in this example, is SevenBridges,
as well.
I think they fall into the same category of
a SaaS.
And as you'll notice, many of them call themselves
platforms, for good reasons, I believe.
So I think what you'll find is that the Data
Commons, therefore, drives this digital ecosystem.
It's the pieces behind it that enable you
to do work with that data.
And so now, what I want to do is switch a
little bit to talk about some Data Commons
Pilots and talk about some of the work that
we're doing in NIH.
I'm not covering all of it.
I'm just covering some examples of that, that
sort of enable you to hopefully understand
a little bit more about the concept of the
platform and the Commons.
So one of the ones we're working on is really
looking at the co-location of large and/or
highly utilized NIH-funded data, with storage
and compute infrastructure, i.e. a cloud.
And they're commonly used tools for the analysis
and the sharing of those digital objects.
The purpose is to create an interoperable
resource for the research community.
Another key factor is, the purpose of the
cloud isn't just necessarily because the data
is large.
It's also a place for collaboration and sharing
of digital objects.
And I think this is one of the key things
that we've also found, that researchers often
do their analysis, they use, say, a cloud
simply because they have large data sets,
but they often want to share or collaborate
as projects are going on.
And collaborators and investigators are located
geographically in different places across
the United States or across the world.
So these environments allow them to do these
kinds of collaborations much more easily,
and look at the output of the results, collaborate
together.
Just want to point out that the Commons that
I'm talking about in the Platform-- there
are the commonses developing out there.
And I want to point out a couple of these.
Probably one of the best-known ones is the
Genomic Data Commons from NCI an NIH, which
is looking at much of the TCGA data loaded
up into that system, then made available exactly
the same way I've been talking about in the
general commons concept.
But certainly, in the last year or so, we've
also seen the emergence of other ones.
So the Fred Hutch Cancer Center over in Seattle,
also, is developing the Hutch Data Commonwealth.
And the New York Genome Center, under Toby
Bloom, has been developing, also, the New
York Genome Center Commons.
There's also been work done at NIH, at NAID,
the Allergy and Infectious Diseases Institute,
developing, essentially, a microbiome platform,
as well, for analysis.
So what we're seeing is a collection of commonses
happening.
The structure of them is very similar to what
I've just described before, is the platform
stack.
They're all using the basic premise, but the
data is somewhat different, depending on what
the particular data sets they are.
But I think it's important to see that they
all have fundamentally the same principles,
and they're all starting to come together.
And one of the other things is, how do we
connect to them?
And I'll get to that in a minute.
So I'm going to talk a little bit, now, about
the Pilot.
But I just want to emphasize that this is
just an
So I'm going to talk a little bit, now, about
the Pilot.
But I just want to emphasize that this is
just an example.
The data sets I'm going to show here are not
the ones we're going to use.
They're just examples of the kinds of things
that we have.
So it's just a draft, but we are actually
working on the principles behind this.
And some time early this year, in the first
quarter, we'll be able to announce some of
the work that we're actually doing in this
area, and some of the specifics around it.
So I'm going to take the platform and just
give an example around some of this.
So I think what we've got here is, we have
a platform.
So we have a collection of different clouds
that we can use.
I think it's important to look at a variety
of different clouds, not just one, in part
because we obviously want to avoid some level
of vendor lock-in.
But I think it also is helpful for supporting
innovation and competition amongst them.
And each one of the systems is different.
They do offer slightly different services.
That's potentially a problem, and also an
opportunity.
So I think we're looking at a collection of
those, which ones we choose is going to be
dependent upon some of the things that we
do based on our use cases.
The other thing we're doing there is looking
at-- if I'm taking this platform, [INAUDIBLE]
we would take a collection of data.
So here are just some examples of data sets,
which are supported by NIH.
I'm not saying that these would be the ultimate
ones we use.
But essentially, what you're creating is a
collection of data.
They're different types, they don't necessarily
interoperate with each other.
But essentially, you're creating a pool of
data that people could potentially query individually
or across, and I think that's pretty important.
And from that is going to come from the need
to potentially harmonize, or not, and that's
a question that we need to look at.
But I think a pool of data would actually
be quite useful to consider.
So if we take that a little bit further, then
we could layer on top of that a series of
analytics and services.
And these are just examples of some of those.
Some of those are commercial, some of them
are not commercial.
Some of them are tools, some of them are tool
systems, some of them are platforms as a service,
and the Global Alliance is obviously looking
at some standard APIs for querying the data.
So this is a collection of things that already
exist out there, that could essentially layer
over the top of this, that could leverage
the data in a variety of different forms and
provide access to the rest of the biomedical
community.
The other thing that I think you want to look
at is, you need to think, obviously, about
the indexing.
And there's work being done inside BD2K with
bioCADDIE, which is an indexing system, and
Bioschemas, which has been discussed with
[? Alexia, ?] which is the group in Europe,
looking at schema [INAUDIBLE] applications
to biomedical sciences.
And I know bioCADDIE has been heavily involved
in looking at those, as well, and incorporating
a lot of that work within DataMed.
But the key point I'm trying to make here
is that you need some form indexing.
I'm pointing out these ones here are just
as examples, in part because we're having
a BD2K lecture, and we are planning to leverage
the work that bioCADDIE [? hands.
?] But it's really critical that you actually
consider the indexing of that.
Otherwise, what you have is a whole lot of
data and a whole lot of tools that are not
necessarily easily findable.
And I think that's really important, to actually
have here and call that in the system.
I think another aspect here is how we would
leverage this, potentially, at NIH.
And I think a real key factor there is, the
things that we can actually do is, if we make
this data available-- these large data sets
available in the cloud, and we can layer on
these tools, I think there are multiple ways
that NIH can foster the innovation of further
development in this area.
The tools that I've laid out here in this--
around the analytics and services are currently
tools that have been developed.
But I think we want to foster more of that.
And I've just given some examples here of--
[? our ones ?] were a bread-and-butter grant
from NIH, but there are other ways to do this.
Essentially, there are ways to get grants
at NIH to foster innovation over the use of
this particular data.
And I think we definitely want to do that.
But I think what we also want to look at is
consider looking challenges and prizes.
Why?
Because I think it could be really interesting
to sort of ask questions across some of this
data, assuming the consents allow us to do
that, to really kind of think about new ways
that you can actually intersect and ask questions
across that data to enable discovery in a
different way.
You can do that, I think, from a couple of
different angles.
One, from a biomedical one, where you can
ask an interesting biomedical question across
these biomedical data sets to improve the
outcome-- the biomarker, some sort of new
discovery, a better understanding of a disease,
all of those are relevant.
But I think what is also relevant is the services
and tools that are needed to do that at a
faster and more accurate rate.
So how well can you predict a biomarker?
What's the best way you can actually do that?
What are the tools that you need to do that?
What's the statistics you need to do that?
Those are some of the aspects, I think, here,
that some of these challenges and prizes could
also address, that I think could yield to
some pretty interesting ways that we could
leverage this particular data.
I think the other thing I want to point out
is that over the top of this whole thing,
you want to have this marketplace, which is--
I'm using the term app store, because that's
where people really have their best understanding
of how it works, when you use an app, and
it works over the top of data, or within your
system.
But I think, really, I'm going towards the
concept of a marketplace.
How do we actually have a collection of tools,
systems, data that you can easily find and
create a marketplace for the way that you
operate over particular data sets or particular
tools?
What's the right way to think about that,
rather than a single way to view a data through
one set of tools alone?
I think that's pretty critical.
Another aspect to consider about here is what
I call the authorization authentication layer,
and there is the-- a lot of this data was
likely to have human subjects issues.
So some will not, but some does.
So for example, human microbiome data does
not, but many of the other data sets do.
So we obviously need to think of the right
way to handle that from NIH.
And much of the data that's human based is
stored at dbGaP at NCBI.
So there's a critical discussion, there, to
happen about, how do you set up the authorization
authentication layer that allows you to get
access to that data in the appropriate way?
And we've been having conversations around
that, within NIH, about how that might actually
occur.
But that's pretty critical, so that you can
ensure that only the people that are permitted
to use the data can actually access that.
Another thing that I want to point out here
is that this isn't the only Commons.
What we're looking at here is NIH-funded data.
But as I pointed out before, there's a collection
of different commonses that are being developed.
And I think what's really important, there,
is that we start talking with them now, not
at the end.
Otherwise, we create cylinders of excellence,
and that's not what we want.
So I've certainly had conversations with all
of the folks that I pointed out before, and
there are more and more folks thinking about
this.
And we've started some discussions around,
what's the right way for these pieces to interact
and intersect?
And where are they separate?
And they need to be separate.
So obviously, one of the most obvious ones
is to look at it through an API access point
between these commonses.
And looking at how we can run services between
them, it's complicated, especially when we
deal with human subjects' data.
But I think the conversation is the important
point here-- that we don't want to simply
look at providing data and creating innovation
on the topic
point here-- that we don't want to simply
look at providing data and creating innovation
on the topic from NIH, and not connecting
to what other folks are already doing in their
other commonses.
So I have some considerations I want to just
talk through now, and that is metrics.
What I'm describing here is essentially a
platform to support biomedical data that uses
cloud data and services.
But understanding how, and you account for
all of the data usage, is really important,
because there will be-- we need to understand
how it's being used and why.
There's also a cost, particularly for these
large data sets.
Cloud storage is not cheap for the large data
sets, particularly if you want to put them
in more than one cloud.
In saying that, many of the commercial providers
are very interested in working with us, because
they see the value of a platform and an ecosystem
that is more than just data storage.
So we are in, obviously, lots of deep conversations
with them about the right way to interact.
This is also a pay-for-use cloud compute.
There is a project which is being developed
in NIH called the NIH credits model, and I'm
not going to speak about that today.
But it's really looking at, how do you pay
for those services directly, and how does
NIH really understand what people are paying
for?
For example, when you are using cloud services,
a lot of the time, you get free credits from
the cloud providers per se, which is great.
But if you probably tried to include everything
that you used on the cloud in your NIH grant,
it probably would be very expensive, and it
would take a fairly large chunk out of your
grant.
There are also other issues that we need to
deal with, which is the indirect costs for
cloud.
When you submit a grant to NIH, there are
indirect costs, which are associated with
the research institution.
And I think what we need to look at is the
way that these things, obviously, interact,
and what's the right way to pay for these
and also to deal with the institutions?
And now, let's be clear-- the commercial clouds
are useful in the sense that they have scale,
but there are many groups out there that have
already developed private or institutional-based
clouds.
And there's good reason for doing that.
Cost is one, privacy of data-- there's been
a lot of concern, if you put this commercial
clouds, what's the right way of handling that?
I think we're still in the midst in determining
those things.
And so I think we will see situations where
hybrid clouds really are important and necessary.
And we need to look at what's the right mix
between those.
And that's pretty-- a very important thing
to look at.
We have to look at managing open- versus controlled-access
data.
The controlled-access data is
obviously related to human.
And we've got to look at, what's the right
way to manage that?
I mentioned that before, that the authorization,
potentially through a single sign-on, is the
way to do that.
But is that really a dream or a nightmare,
because it's-- from what we've seen, it's
really a very complicated set of things to
do.
And there may be reasons where a single sign-on
is good, but there may be situations where
that's not possible, so we need to sort of
test all of that and figure out what's the
right way to approach it.
It's important to point out that we need to
look at the difference between archiving versus
working and versioning copies of the data.
NIH requires that we keep all our data, certainly
the-- we archive it.
That's where very large archives like NCBI
are very important in EBI over in Europe.
But if we put working copies of the data onto
the cloud, they're not archives, and we need
to know that that's what we're actually doing
and why.
Another one is, if we do move copies of large
data sets to the cloud, obviously, versioning
is going to be pretty important.
So how do we handle that?
That leads to all sorts of issues around syncing,
and I think whatever we do in testing this,
we need to figure that out.
Another one, which I mentioned before, is
interoperability with other commonses.
Many of them are going to be based on clouds.
The ones I mentioned to you before are going
to be based on clouds.
And it would be important to ensure that we
don't have these cylinders of excellence,
that we actually have interoperability between
these clouds.
We also have standards around metadata, UIDs,
and the APIs.
And the key, I think, here is to reuse what
we've already-- available to us in the community.
There is work being done, certainly within
BD2K around metadata templates by Mark Musen's
group at CEDAR.
There's a lot of work being done by various
groups with UIDs, and there's the Global Alliance,
which has been looking at open-standard APIs.
There's also work being done within some commons,
smaller efforts looking at open-standard APIs
that incorporate metadata, and that are smart,
and actually know they can find different
APIs and locate them, so that we have a better
understanding of what's available to us.
But this is critically an important area that
we need to have further development in.
Discoverability touches on the indexing issue.
I mentioned bioCADDIE before, but we need
to look at-- bioCADDIE's one place to start.
And it's a really good place to have-- to
use.
But there are other ways to do that, and we
need to-- and the field is changing, so we
need to figure out what's the right way to
support that kind of work.
And particularly, if we're going to have data
and digital
the right way to support that kind of work.
And particularly, if we're going to have data
and digital objects of various sorts across
different clouds, that's going to be an interesting
problem to try and solve, as well.
Regarding interfaces, I think that's really
pretty critical, because you've got users
with different needs and different capabilities.
Certainly, in the early versions of what we're
trying to do here, will probably the most
usable by those that have a whole lot of bioinformatics
capabilities already, and understanding.
But we understand very clearly that biomedical
researchers don't necessarily have the capacity,
all the time, to have bioinformaticians in
their group.
And so we need to be able to have interfaces
that are available to biologists that don't
have those capabilities, but definitely want
to be able to use the data.
So that's something we're really being very
mindful of in all of these pieces.
Consent-- this is a really important piece.
So we're getting onto some policy pieces here.
Reconsenting of the data may be necessary,
and that also could be very complex, particularly
if you're trying to traverse across two different
data sets that weren't consented to be using
for the purpose of using them to mine across
two data sets.
So we have to be very mindful of those consents
in the first place.
And so engaging with the right folks to talk
about that is really important.
We've certainly been doing that at NIH.
There are policies that need to be also considered
in such an endeavor, and that is the data
sharing policies that are useful and effective
to support this kind of open science.
We have some already at NIH, but I certainly
think we need a further focus on this, and
there are certainly efforts underway at NIH
to do this.
And I think we need more effort in this area,
and I think NIH understands that.
I think we also need to keep pace with the
use of technology.
And here, the example I'd give you is the
example of dbGaP data in the cloud.
This is-- a couple of years ago, the policy
precluded the use of dbGaP data in the cloud.
This was a big problem for researchers, since
they wanted to use that data in the cloud,
because they had-- it was large, and they
also had large data that they wanted to compare
it against.
But policies precluded the use of that.
And so a group of us, including myself, helped
change some of the policies around that to
enable the use of dbGaP data in the cloud.
So sometimes what happens is, technology is
further ahead than the policies.
And we need to do a good job of making sure
that these two things are aligned.
And again, it means that we talk-- in the
case, the Office of Science Policy, and work
with those people to ensure that they understand
what we're trying to do,
and vice versa, so we can keep up to speed
with the changes in the technologies.
I think incentives are incredibly important
here for the shareability of FAIR data, as
part of the grant review criteria of NIH.
By that I mean, when you submit an application
to NIH, you obviously missed all of your papers,
but it would be really good if people could
also cite their data and software, and any
of the other data assets-- digital assets
that you have in a way that's meaningful and
consistent.
So I think we don't have any incentives in
there right now, but I think we're really
looking at the fact that if data becomes currency,
and FAIR data becomes currency, what's the
right way to include that in the review system
when you're putting in applications to NIH?
I think we also need to look at governance,
which is, how do we do this?
How do we actually govern the overall way
that we handle a commons?
I think what's critical here is to have community
involvement in this governance model that
isn't just generated by NIH.
If this is really going to be an open-- a
platform for open science, and an ecosystem
to be able to use data at scale and to share
it, then I think getting an understanding
from community involvement is really important.
And I think a key one here, the last one I've
got here on my slides, is sustainability.
We all know that grants have a cycle at NIH,
and then they end.
So what's the long-term support for this?
If we do move data, for example, in the cloud
for some of these large data sets, how do
we sustain that in the longer term?
What's the right business model to do that,
and what's the right way to attempt to do
that?
I think these are all questions that we're
having in terms of what we are trying to think
about, how we approach the commons.
So I think I've got just to my last slide
here, which is the acknowledgements.
And there's a lot of people that have been
involved in this.
And most-- there will be some folks who recognize
the names here.
But my point I want to make out is that there's
a lot of work happening across NIH that isn't
just within one Institute.
It's across many institutes and in places
that are unusual, so to speak, and sometimes
we do bio work.
And that is CIT, the Center for Information
Technology, and Andrea Norris's group, who's
also the CIO of NIH, which is all the pure
computing side has been working heavily with
us.
Also, Common Fund, who's very interested in
this kind of work, has been working with us.
I've listed, also, the Clinical Center is
working with us-- the NIH Clinical Center--
to look at some of their data.
And also, the Office of Science Policy.
So it's a collection of folks across NIH.
But I'd also like to just have a shout-out
to Research and Industry.
We've spent a lot of time
working with our industry, primarily cloud
providers, but also the SaaS providers, and
also other folks in the community developing
commonses.
And they have been providing really good and
helpful input into the way we're thinking
about the commons.
So it's really a unified effort across NIH
in these discussions, in places not just across
certain institutes and centers, but in places
that wouldn't normally be involved in this.
So it's really touching on the issue that
data is really the currency of the way we
have to go forward.
So I'm just going to end by just saying thank
you for your time.
I hope that this has helped you understand
a little bit about the path that we took to
the Data Commons, that we have some idea of
some Pilots we want to do for these large
data sets.
And in the coming months, we'll be able to
explain a lot more detail around what that
will be.
But essentially, what NIH would like to do
is to enable the use and access to NIH data
sets to the community.
And the innovation we hope will come from
the community, and how you will use those
data, and how you will actually develop tools,
systems, services, platforms, et cetera, over
the top of that.
The data sets are large, and they cost.
I think this is where NIH really needs to
play in the game, and we need to help the
community get access to that data so that
we can innovate both in the data science realm,
as well as the biomedical realm, so that we
can actually foster new discoveries.
All right, I think that's where I'm going
to stop right now.
And I think we're going to take some questions,
is that right?
It is.
Thank you, Vivien, for this great overview,
and for giving us an update on what's going
on with the NIH data commons.
So we've actually got quite a few questions
for you.
I'll just go through some of them.
We'll start with this first one, which sort
of has to do with the fees that are always
associated with big data.
And this is actually touching on the veracity
component.
And the question is really, given that we're
moving toward these sort of open data repositories,
and public access to this information, and
obviously, sharing the information, as well,
and people being able to put their own data
into it, how do you know that you can trust
the data?
How do we actually get to veracity of data?
Right, and I think that comes down to some
of the FAIR guidelines, and making sure that
you know that when people apply them, what's
the right way that we can-- I don't want to
use the term policing, but we need to know
that we can do that.
And that's a complex issue.
I think if we can
agree to a set of guidelines of what FAIRness
is, and then we can empower ourselves to use
those guidelines, I think that's important.
I think another thing that we need to consider
is that, as people start using them, if more
transactions happen on quality FAIR data,
if they meet the guidelines, then the incentives
kick into play, right?
So if more people are using the data, and
it's in FAIR format, and it's compliant, and
you can quote it, say, for example, in an
application for NIH, that's a good thing.
So are there are ways to do that where it's
actually driven, in part, by policing policy-making.
And some of it is, I think, pushed by the
community, where if we agree to a standard,
it makes the transactions and the systems
stronger, and the data more usable and more
quotable.
So I think it comes from a combination of
two different things.
And I think it also comes from the fact that
we don't yet know how to do all of that.
But knowing the fact that the data can be
dirty, and not quality, I think is really
important, too.
So I think it allows for a little bit of wiggle
room to say, I don't think we know, yet, the
entirety of the system.
OK, I mean, it-- definitely, it is an open
question.
And it's how do we look at that?
So following up on that sort of question is
another one from-- regarding the culture of
data sharing.
And what is your perception of where the community
is in terms of this new culture of data sharing?
Do you feel that there is a broad acceptance,
or a growing acceptance?
What proportion of scientists and researchers
do you feel are embracing the data sharing
and participating in it, versus those that
are basically going to have to be mandated
to do the data sharing?
Well, this will be my entire opinion, but
I can try and address it from couple of different
regions.
My own personal view is that the participants
come from a couple of different regions.
I certainly notice it with the younger generation.
So the postdocs and the grad students-- their
openness, their approach, they come from open.
So their mindset is open.
So they tend to share.
I think as you go up the seniority stack,
so to speak, some of the PIs who are there
now, who come from an older generation, don't
have that kind of mindset.
So that creates some issues.
But that's not true of all of them.
I think some certainly see the value of it.
But the mentality, I think, has been changing
in the current generations and the ones that
are coming through now.
So that's one of the things that I see.
And so as the grad students are going through
the system, and becoming professors within
departments, they'll bring their culture with
them.
It will take time, but I think we're going
to see that.
And also, I think we've got some, perhaps,
enlightened souls who are pretty senior in
their
organizations, who are also beacons of trying
to push this through.
And I think there are plenty of examples that
we see.
So the combination of those, I think, are
what I see changing.
I think the funding institutions play a crucial
role in this.
And that is that the funding institutions
also have to provide incentives.
So as I mentioned during my talk, you need
to think about-- well, we at NIH, need to
think about the way that this enters the review
system.
So if there is an incentive for a digital
asset that has either-- primarily, data or
software is where the talk is right now--
that has, for example, a DOI associated with
it, that that can actually be listed as something
very important in your grant application.
And that that has value and weight within
the way that NIH sees it.
And when it does, a review.
It's not just about your paper.
It's all about the other things that have
occurred, as well.
And there, it touches on the fact of what
you just mentioned before, which is, well,
if I've got a bunch of these things, and I
have DOIs, how do I know that the quality
of that data is high, or not just a bunch
of data that is meaningless?
So what are the bars there?
And I think the application there is, how
do we do that?
And I don't think we know yet, and we have
to look at it.
But I think it's really important that NIH
think about the way that they set up incentives
for that, and they also have policies in place
which are the-- I guess the stick part of
the carrot and the stick, where there is some
level of ensuring that the community follows
some rules.
But I think it would be wrong for NIH to simply
use the stick all the time.
It would be good to have both of those in
play, in part because that's the nature of
the way systems work, and not all humans play
fair.
So I think it would be really good to see
if we could have a combination of those.
That's just sort of my broad, general view
of what I'm seeing with the culture change.
I'm certainly seeing it changing more and
more.
Every year, I see changes.
And that's, I think, a good thing towards
open.
I would agree with you on that.
I think there is a culture change that is
happening.
It's not happening overnight, but it is slowly
percolating up and becoming more common.
Another question, and this is going to some
of the comments-- or some of the remarks you
made regarding bioCADDIE and other sort of
efforts.
The question revolves around researchers being
able to find the most appropriate resources
for their needs.
And I would assume that that is both with
respect to data and the tools and software.
Could you comment further on other sort of
works that bioCADDIE or other groups that
you're aware of are doing to sort of help
researchers in this regard?
aware of are doing to sort of help researchers
in this regard?
Sure.
So I think this is a wide-open field.
So I think bioCADDIE has been doing a lot
of work in this area, to try and find ways
of indexing resources.
And I think we're in the early days of that.
I'm not going to go into the details of bioCADDIE
here, in part because I know it to a certain
degree, but I think the question is more relevant
broadly.
I think there's a lot of efforts happening,
both in industry as well as in research.
I've certainly seen it within BD2K, that there
are different slants on the way that you might
want to look at discoverability.
It partly depends on what you want to find
and how you want to find it.
Some things are more discoverable than others
because of their metadata.
Sometimes they're different kind of objects.
Sometimes you're going to find software, sometimes
you don't.
So there are multiple research and commercial
efforts underway.
And I think what we need to do is to sort
of do some bake-offs to see, how do they work
against some of the data and tools that we
have?
How does that work?
And I think we're just starting to begin that
whole process.
I'll give you an example of some of the work
I've done with Zenodo, over at CERN in Europe.
They're looking at how that they-- both a
repository, but also access points for data
and tools.
How can they search for that?
So what's the right way to do that?
And then once you do find it, how do you connect
it with a service?
How do you do something with it once you've
actually found it?
I think there is that, and then an obvious
one, of course, is, Google's really good at
this kind of stuff.
And a lot of their work around schema.org,
which is now being incorporated into bioschema.org,
I think is another effort to look at, how
do you leverage ways that methodologies related
to discoverability can be used in more appropriate
ways for biomedicine?
So for example, I know that bioCADDIE has
been moving towards incorporating a lot of
that work within its own DataMed component.
So I think it's a wide-open field, and it's
both got industry as well as researchers across
the world looking at this.
And I think we're at the stage where we really
need to start probing into, what are the different
resources that are available?
How do they do it differently?
And is it-- does it impact what you're searching
for?
If a different-- does it matter which type
of digital asset you're searching for?
I think that's currently where we've been
thinking at NIH.
And I think the work that we've seen from
bioCADDIE has been helping us better understand
the way that the community is thinking about
it.
And as bioCADDIE has been looking at indexing
various data sets, we're sort of seeing the
outcome of those, and saying, well, that one
worked, and this one didn't work so well.
So that helps us feed back into the system
to say what we need to actually do.
It's a pretty general answer, but I think
that's just generally where we're at the moment.
Fair enough.
I think that there are, obviously, lots of
BD2K-specific projects that are also looking
at indexing from different perspectives.
I know that there's ones from UCLA, and there
are others throughout the different centers
of excellence, so-- And I think the good thing
is that they're all coming together under
one umbrella.
So actually, there was a question that was
posed, which is talking about FAIR framework,
and the working groups around that.
I think I can answer that for you, in this
particular case.
Someone asked, how do you go about finding
out more about FAIR and joining the working
group?
There is a Commons framework working groups
that actually addresses FAIR and other aspects.
And we'll make that information available
more broadly to the community after this talk,
if individuals are interested in finding out
more about FAIR and the various working groups
that Vivien has mentioned.
Yeah, that-- I would add, Alex, there, that
Valentina di Francesco over at NHGRI is the
contact person for this-- from the NIH perspective,
too.
Yes.
So one last question before we go.
This has to do, again, with the platform and
the idea of collaboration.
Do you envision any types of collaborative
tools to support active collaboration, or
being more proactive in forging collaborations
within the cloud-- or not within the cloud,
within the Commons?
So things like being able to communicate,
find researchers-
Yes.
So I-- yes, I do.
And I think that layer is often not seen by--
often by NIH.
But for example, figshare, that does a lot
of these connections, [INAUDIBLE].
There are groups out there that have pieces
of information that would be really useful
to connect with in this environment, not just
the data.
There are also people that are developing
collaborative-- tools for collaboration that
allow connections, data to tools through services,
but also ways to do other things, like linking
to scholarly research and scholarly papers,
journals, publications, et cetera.
And there are several groups looking at that,
and have actually developed some platforms
in this area.
And I think we need to look at what that will
be, because one, the way that they're developing
those collaborative platforms, so to speak,
are a lot easier for biologists to use.
They don't-- there's a lower learning curve.
curve.
And the cloud, to some extent, if it's being
used, is hidden in the background.
But it's still being used, but it's a whole
lot easier for the people to connect to it.
If you think about it, like, for example,
I gave the example of AirBnB.
You can see it immediately.
You just see the picture of what you want,
and then you can connect to it.
All the pieces that happen underneath, behind
it, the data, the cloud, all the rest of it,
is visible to you.
But it means that anyone can use that platform.
And I think that's where the collaboration
pieces fit into play with some of these tools.
They're going to enable more and more people
to use these environments, and it's going
to enable them to do science faster, and at
scale, with lower levels of computing capability.
And that's fine, because many biologists don't
have that.
What we have to do is, we're right at the
start of figuring out, if this is what we're
looking at as the ecosystem, what do we need
to test?
And there's a lot of technology we need to
test before we can get to the place where
it becomes smooth transactions in that environment.
Hope that helps.
That's great.
So thank you again, Vivien.
I know it's 10:00, at least on the west coast.
Thank you for your time in this presentation.
We've had a lot of great questions and discussion.
And [INAUDIBLE] the insights you provided
were wonderful.
Sure.
I'm happy to take questions offline.
I think my desktop still has my email address.
I'm happy to take private questions about
this.
You can find me in different places.
I'm also going to put this presentation up
on SlideShare after this meeting, in the spirit
of open science, just making sure everything's
open.
Great.
Thank you again.
Thanks so much, everyone.
Have a good day.